from his early days with britain's
national swim team to his current status
as one of the world's most bangable
movie stars jason statham has lived an
interesting life if you want to learn
more about the iconic english action
hero here's the untold truth of jason
statham
if jason statham is starring in a movie
you best believe that there's going to
be some action involved whether it's an
adrenaline-pumping car chase a
bullet-spraying shootout or a good
old-fashioned bare-handed beatdown the
action star seems to feed off of stunt
work and more often than not statham is
actually the one performing the stunts
too as he explained to ign i'll do more
if they let me i've never really been
frightened to do anything in an
interview with the guardian the
transporter star talked about how his
early ambition of becoming a stuntman
was initially sparked by watching a man
doing a high dive into a hotel pool
saying he'd done this sort of reverse
layout and i was like i'd love to do
that years later the young daredevil had
mastered the craft of diving and he was
even selected to compete for the british
national team in the 1990 commonwealth
games although statham ultimately
retired from the sport perhaps his
intense diving training helped hone his
body for the demanding stunt work that
his film career would bring
a lot of today's biggest actors and
actresses were taught how to hone their
craft through years of studying drama or
performing in prestigious theater
productions jason statham however
apparently has a bit of a different
origin story than your typical a-lister
when speaking to esquire the crank actor
opened up about how his father taught
him to hustle on the london street when
he was just a teenager saying not sit
down outside of harrods and i'd pitch
the jewelry and what i'm selling is
costume jewelry basically but i'm
selling it with a bit of street theater
and having a bit of fun with it making a
living an actor is nothing if not a
skilled salesman right statham went on
to boast that he was such a talented
hustler that he could pull in as much as
three thousand dollars in a weekend so
what did the future fast and furious
star say he'd spend all that go on with
by cars and with race cars i've always
loved statham literally went from
hawking sketchy goods on street corners
to starring and blockbuster action
movies but throughout it all the man's
love for automobiles has remained strong
who says bromance is dead jason statham
and guy ritchie the well-renowned
director of action flicks like 2017's
king arthur legend of the sword proved
that having a dependable go-to guy can
be a real asset in hollywood the duo
make up a powerful actor director combo
joining the ranks of other successful
tag teams richie is actually the man
responsible for jump starting sathan's
acting career casting him as bacon in
1998's luck stock and two smoking
barrels despite the fact that he had
absolutely zero acting experience as
statham explained to esquire richie who
had met through an earlier modeling gig
approached him about the role because
the streetwise character was similar to
statham saying he just wanted someone
who was authentic he said i'm gonna get
someone from drama school to do this how
can they learn what you've learned after
log stock and two smoking barrels the
two collaborated again in 2000 snatch
and 2005's revolver in an interview with
yahoo entertainment the sherlock holmes
director had nothing but kind words for
his british bff as he put it jason
statham is one of my most favorite
people in the entire world he's grumpy
and he's one of the few grumpy people
that doesn't annoy me in any way
in 1986 nestle executives introduced the
world to one of the catchiest
commercials in american history give me
a break give me a break break me up a
piece of that kitkat bar but over in the
uk candy lovers were more familiar with
a different slogan one that went have a
break
have a kitkat the catchphrase lasted for
47 years up until the early 2000s when a
company spokesperson announced a change
in their market approach part of that
plan involved a brand new slogan made
the most of your break and another piece
of that advertising campaign involved
one of england's hottest names at the
time jason statham writing the success
of popular films like 2002's the
transporter and 2003's the italian job
statham nabbed a partnership with the
candy company making him the break
philosopher the actor starred in a total
of three ads for kitkat and the brands
then account director emma stewart smith
was very pleased with their selection
explaining jason statham was the best
choice he is down to earth and credible
when telling the stories he hasn't done
ads before so people tend to listen to
him more also women fancy him and men
think he's a good bloke although they've
been around for about 20 years the
commercials are still pretty funny today
statham's love life proves that age is
nothing but a number the british third
has dated a number of beautiful women
throughout the past few decades and most
of them have been younger than him by
double digits stay from dated english
model and media personality kelly brook
for seven years before ultimately
calling it quits in 2004. he then spent
nearly a year with former bachelorette
starlet sophie monk before getting
serious with alex zosman who he'd go on
to date until early 2010 after he and
zasman parted ways the expendable star
was spotted out with former victoria's
secret angel rosie huntington whiteley
despite their 20-year age difference the
pair who got engaged in 2016 have now
been going strong for over 10 years
sylvester stallone's expendables movies
don't exactly shy away from killing the
total kill count in the 2010 original
tallies up to 221 deaths a number that's
more than doubled in its explosive
sequel 2012's expendables 2. for the
third installment and the grizzly
franchise jason statham apparently
nearly wound up on the kill count in
real life after a dangerous stunt went
awry when speaking to the mirror at the
expendables 3 premiere in 2014 stallone
told the tale of how his co-star had a
very close call during the film's
production saying he faced death he was
test driving a three-ton truck and the
brakes run out statham doing his own
stunts per usual crashed the runaway
vehicle into the black sea according to
stallone if it had been anyone else
driving the truck they most likely would
have died saying we would have drowned
but because jason is an olympic quality
diver he got out of it years later
statham recalled the near-death
experience during an interview with the
red bulletin noting how it changed his
attitude it's a real recalibration of
everything from that day on i've been so
appreciative of life and being able to
walk on the ground i think we all need
an experience like that one that puts
things in perspective unlike some of the
action heroes he's portrayed on the big
screen statham seemingly understands
that he's not invincible
jason statham's filmography proves that
he's always up for joining a multi-film
franchise in addition to the wildly
popular expendables and fast and furious
cinematic universes he's also filmed a
number of sequels to his own films such
as transporter 2 and 3 crank 2 high
voltage and mechanic resurrection
strangely enough there's one
multi-billion dollar entity that the
british bad boy opted out of the marvel
cinematic universe when speaking to den
of geek in 2017 marvel boss kevin feige
confirmed that he had once considered
statham for a role in the mcu but
scheduling conflicts kept it from
happening feige had nothing but nice
things to say of the action icon noting
that the actor even called him after the
fact to apologize explaining he was
saying sorry it didn't work out maybe
next time he couldn't have been nicer
the role he was considered for is
anyone's guess but some fans believe
that statham was up for the part of
notorious daredevil baddie bullseye this
news was somewhat surprising considering
that statham had made some pretty
disrespectful comments about marvel
movies when speaking to italian website
e-400 couchy a couple years earlier
saying i could take my grandma and put
her in a cape and they'll put her on a
green screen and they'll have stunt
doubles come in and do all the action
anybody can do it honestly if statham's
grandma is anything like he is then she
probably would make a believable
superhero
in 2005's thrilling revolver jason
statham plays a scheming gambler named
jake green while in prison green
discovers a formulaic game-winning
strategy with the help of two fellow
inmates a skilled con man and a chess
master and as it turns out the green
skills on the chessboard are apparently
something that he shared with the film
star in real life in an interview with
cinema.com statham spoke about the
competitive relationship he has with
revolver's director and long-time friend
guy ritchie noting that they are fierce
chess rivals ah it's beautiful man
you have to admire the opponent's
elegance
check
to hear him tell it he's clearly the
superior player the toughest moment is
getting guy richie to pay his debts when
he loses a chess he just won't pay up he
won't accept the loss i have to live
with that however richie has also
playfully claimed that he doesn't
respect statham as a chess player so the
jury is still out as to which talented
celebrity is a real chess wiz
in 2013's underrated action thriller
homefront statham plays phil broker a
recently widowed former dea agent who
moves to a small louisiana town to raise
his young daughter when things go
sideways and the town's drug dealer
targets the new family it's up to broker
to fend off the bad guys and keep his
kids safe statham plays a paternal role
with great authenticity which was
perhaps an indicator of things to come
in june 2017 statham and his fiancee
rosie huntington-whiteley welcomed their
firstborn son jack oscar to the world
since then statham has looked every bit
the part of a proud and typical dad
young jack certainly has a bright future
with such talented parents to look up to
when speaking to now this the meg's
leading man opened up about how becoming
a dad truly changed his life and
reshuffled his priorities saying you
learn as soon as you become a dad that
all your selfish desires have put on a
very large back burner it's an
incredible transition and it's the
greatest feeling in the world he may be
a tough guy on screen but fatherhood
proves that statham may have a soft side
after all i'm a big soft beat and i get
told off being tucson
in 2018 shrilling shark tailed the meg
statham played jonas taylor a scorned
ex-rescue diver with a personal vendetta
against a mysterious massive underwater
beast that only he believes is real when
the creature which is revealed to be a
gargantuan prehistoric shark called a
megalodon eventually rears its ugly head
again it's up to taylor and crew to find
it and take it down before it unleashes
an aquatic killing spree it's like jaws
on steroids while the film's enormous
man-eater is only a product of cgi and
bad dreams don't get it twisted statham
probably would have hopped in the water
even if the thing was real in an
interview with entertainment weekly the
notorious english daredevil recalled a
time when he went diving with bull
sharks in fiji admitting that it was an
ordeal being inches away from a swarm of
the large toothy fish saying all of the
fear or the perceived fear is done in
your own head before you get down there
with them so once you're swimming down
there with all the other divers it's
phenomenal it's one of the greatest
experiences you could have for me anyway
swimming in shark-infested waters is
apparently just another relaxing day in
the life of jason statham check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more luba videos about your
favorite action stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]